(dramatic sounds)
- I love me some cheese.
- I love cheese more
than I love some people.
- The stinkier, the better.
- I like cheese, yeah,
but I don't ususally
get that adventurous with it.
- The stinkiest cheese I've eaten is brie
and that's not even really that stinky.
- You know some people have wine cellars,
I just want a cellar full of
different types of cheeses.
(string instruments)
- Can you smell it?
- I just got a huge whiff of that.
- So we're supposed to eat the mold?
- If I went on a first
date and someone's breath
smelled like this I would
immediately run away
but really maybe he's just really refined.
- It's got a nice gooey texture.
- Wow that's really good.
- It smells like a foot fungus.
- Is it weird that I like the taste of it?
- I would put this into my cheese cellar.
- Slosh? Schloss? Schloss.
- It's got the mold hairs
which is disgusting.
- Aw, come on man!
- This one's gonna be good just based on
how much it smells.
- It's like gym socks that you've kept
in the same bag for three weeks.
- It smells like a crotch.
- It's like you know one
of those silent farts
that you like don't hear
and then all of a sudden you're just like
'oh shit who did that?!'
- I do not like that at all.
- I'm sorry.
- It's not as bad as it smells.
- Yeah it's not as bad as it smells.
- Like look I'm still gonna
eat it because it's cheese
but it's probably my
least favorite so far.
- You will literally put
anything in your mouth.
- I'm gonna keep goin.
- I would also put this
into my cheese cellar.
- I am not going in that cellar.
- Ugh, another cheese. I was so excited
at the beginning of this.
- Me too.
- This one really sweats.
- It smells like canned sardines.
- Oh Jesus Christ.
- That one tastes a lot
stronger than it smells.
- But in a good way.
- Tastes like spoiled swiss.
- When I first put this in my mouth,
I thought I was gonna straight throw up.
- Me too.
- And then the after
taste I was like 'mm.'
- It's just all cheese is good cheese.
(laughter)
- As you die.
- Ugh.
- I'm gonna actually flip flop on this
and say the less stinky the
cheese, the better it is.
- Who woulda known I like stinky cheese?
- I appreciate it but I
don't want it inside me.
- Just try it and see if you like it.
- I might be a little more
adventurous with cheese now.
- Don't judge a cheese by its smell.
- I probably wouldn't eat this on a date.
- I think if you have this on the date
and your partner's into it,
you guys are gonna have
really great, nasty sex.
- Oh yes!